yeah I was able to tell her shortly
before she died that I was gonna have a
baby
Anderson Cooper's mom Gloria Vanderbilt
may have died before she got to meet her
grandson but Anderson made sure she knew
about him I was in the process of it
yeah she was thrilled the CNN anchor
announced the happy news last week that
he's officially a dad on Monday I became
a father never actually said that before
out loud and it's all kind of astonishes
me and on Mondays live with Kelly and
Ryan Anderson revealed that he was able
to tell his mom that he was planning to
be a father before she died in June why
have you been created at that point was
actually a being at that point but yeah
he was an idea in my head and I was I
was in the process of it all that echoes
what Gloria told ET when we caught up
with her and Anderson in 2016 Anderson
welcomed wyatt via a surrogate and while
he's only been a dad for a week
he says it's already changed him it's
amazing astana
it's just I don't know I just stared him
and I like ours will go by and I realize
I've just been sitting there holding
heaven and he's like a little tiny like
I don't know little tiny frog or
something it's so cute and I just can't
help him and and then like you know
babies sleep a lot so but you know then
he'll suddenly like open up his eyes and
look at you and I don't even know if you
can see me at this stage but it seems
like any sort of you know understanding
sounds and it's just wild it's um it's
way way better than that flex
now there's an ad for Parenthood babies
there are better than Netflix and
according to Anderson at 52 years old
caffeine is a new
I'll staple in his life oh I like it -
iced coffee I've never had coffee but
I've had it like once or twice on TV and
never in real life and yeah now I I
don't know I can't believe that lasted
this long like I've a lot of friends a
night and now I understand why people
drink coffee now Anderson welcome to our
coffee club better late than never
cheers to young Wyatt the veteran
journalist also opened up about the
inspiration behind a Wyatt's name
explaining that why it was actually his
dad's name
he died when Anderson was just 10 years
old I always thought if I had a boy I
would name - Wyatt and Morgan is my
mom's grandmother's maiden name
oh no grandmother's name and my mom's
mom's maiden name and yeah so I wanted
something from my mom and so yeah why
Mountain Burger Anderson first announced
his baby boy on his CNN show Anderson
360 this is Wyatt Cooper he is three
days old and understandably he got
emotional
I do wish my mom and my dad and my
brother Carter were alive to meet Wyatt
but I like to believe that they can see
him I imagine them all together arms
around each other smiling and laughing
and watching looking down on us happy to
know that their love is alive in me and
in Wyatt and that our family continues
Anderson later shared these sweet pics
of his itty-bitty on Instagram writing
in part quote as a gay kid I never
thought it would be possible to have a
child and I'm grateful for all those who
have paved the way
fans friends and family were quick to
hit up social media to congratulate
Anderson on his bundle of joy and his
co-worker Chris Cuomo shared these
touching words on the air you will honor
the memory of your loved ones in the way
you never imagined through how you love
this kid and your waspy ass is gonna
emote in a way that you
ever you're gonna cry with a frequency
your than ever imagined but he looks at
you what he recognizes you you will see
my friend this is going to be the best
thing that ever happened in your life in
his too
[Music]